verschwindende geräusche die viele fast
vergessen haben faszinieren jan derksen
[Applaus]
ich bin ja der achsen und ich bin einer
der macher von consol sound das ist ein
online museum für verschiedene geräusche
rund 120 verschiedene geräusche sind
schon in dem online archiv vom dia
projektor bis zur sofortbildkamera und
es werden immer mehr
denn geräusche die aus dem alltag
verschwinden finden jan derksen und sein
mitarbeiter als jürgen meyer überall
angefangen in ihrer heimatstadt essen im
westen deutschlands
wir gehen jetzt ins schausteller kinos
museum in essen und wir hoffen dass wir
da ganz viele tolle alte geräusche
finden und ganz viele alte tolle geräte
weil auf der internetseite haben schon
ganz viele tolle fotos gesehen und wir
sind schon gespannt was wir finden das
markt und schausteller museum essen wird
seit 1985 ehrenamtlich betrieben in der
sammlung rund 9000 objekte aus mehr als
200 jahren schausteller geschichte
eine fundgrube für die macher von
conserve bislang und besonders angetan
sind sie von dieser drehorgel aus dem
jahr 1914 von früher irgendwie also
kenntnis dieses eigentlich dass er
wirklich so dieser ikonische sound von
soja merken immer wenn auch noch
heutzutage eigentlich ein film zum
jahrmarkt erzählt wieder hört man genau
die zone super vorbereitungen für die
ton- und fotoaufnahmen der drehorgel
dazu genügt ein kleiner mobiler rekorde
und ein mikrofon für jahren sachsen
haben die so gesammelten klänge eine
ganz eigene qualität
[Musik]
das besondere an den verschiedenen
geräuschen ist dass das wirklich direkt
ja so eine persönliche erinnerungen bei
den menschen sofort wach ruft sie können
wir einen klick oder mit einem mit einem
geräusche in ganz bestimmten situation
wieder zurück verfolgt oder
zurückversetzt werden und man ist sofort
wieder eben auf dem jahrmarkt zum
beispiel wo man mit fünf irgendwas nicht
1950 über den jahrmarkt gelaufen ist
trotzdem belassen ist die macher nicht
beim reinen geräusch sondern
fotografieren die klangwelle auch die
ursprüngliche idee wirklich nur die
klänge zu präsentieren haben sie bald
wieder verworfen
das war ja wirklich auch im internet
funktionieren und im inhalt ist es
leider so dass es der freiheit hält das
visuelle dem mond hat auch schön
aussehen deswegen ist ganz klar dass wir
da auch immer noch versuchen schöne
fotos von den gegenständen zu machen
beruflich betreibt jan der achsen ein
studio für kommunikationsdesign einige
sammlerstücke im büro erzählen
beispielhaft wie geräusche allmählich
verschwinden zweifel ein klassiker von
uns was man auch bei uns auf der seite
findet es natürlich dieses schöne
wählscheiben telefon erst abheben
natürlich ja als condor dazu haben wir
dann quasi die weiterentwicklung dieser
tollen kleinen handys die machen
natürlich viel weniger geräusche nur
noch ganz kleine ganz genau hinhört und
dann später wurde es dann ganz lautlos
auf den ersten smartphones um eine
völlig lautlos nur noch nicht gegen
gewicht hat
die heutigen foto und tonaufnahmen
werden bearbeitet und anschließend
online gestellt geld verdienen die
macher mit konzerte sound nicht
das projekt lebt von fördergeldern aber
ein ende ist nicht in sicht
es gibt jede menge geräusche die man
noch suchen und finden kann also
eigentlich das ja ein lebenslanges
projekt also solange es die menschheit
gibt und solange der mensch geräusche
produziert könnte man dieses projekt
endlich weiterführen konserve sound eine
digitale zeitreise mit klängen und
geräuschen die mehr sagen als tausend
bilder